deuxième partie de cette voie libre
spéciale consacrée à la fin de l'année à
102 de dijon-longvic on a parlé de son
histoire de ce qui s'y passe encore on
va se pencher maintenant sur la suite
avec le colonel pierre réal dernier
commandant de cette base rebonjour de la
mède real le drapeau du régiment ou de
la base vous à rejoindre
on en parlera je l'aimais d'amer de
longvic vice président du grand dijon et
le colonel bertrand françois qui va
commander l'école de gendarmerie qui
s'installe sur le site c'est un des
thèmes dont nous allons parler
maintenant
bonjour oui bonjour tout d'abord cette
base aérienne qui ferme c'est le
cinquième employeurs de côte-d'or qui
ferment comment vous allez réussi à
surmonter ça une catastrophe économique
quelque part pour le grand dijon
c'était une très mauvaise nouvelle en
fait quand c'est tombé en fait en 2014
et c'est vrai que nous avons dû faire
face selon la devise de guynemer face à
sète à cette très mauvaise nouvelle et
en proposant un nouveau projet vous
n'avez pas réussi à faire pression
finalement là c'était un échec quelque
part des politiques de la région
c'est vrai que c'était une décision
d'état qui était une décision
géostratégique en fait que de décider
d'arrêter de fermer cette base
comme d'autres avant à reims par exemple
la différence c'est que nous souhaitions
que ça ne devienne pas une friche quoi
donc nous avions eu là pour le coup la
volonté de rebondir et de proposer autre
chose
grâce à l'appui de personnalités
politiques on va dire quand on simule
tanner ya là le départ de la base
aérienne et puis à l'arrêt en grande
partie des lignes régulières de
l'aviation civile qui avait aussi qu'ils
utilisaient aussi c'est us c'est un
double coup en réalité un double coup
d'arrêt en fait vous avez totalement
raison de dire ça s'arrêterait à ça a
été très compliqué de gérer cette
situation pour les élus locaux que nous
sommes pour autant on a eu des appuis
majeur décisif notamment de la part de
france en examen n qui était alors
ministre et président du grand dijon qui
nous a permis en fait d'avancé à la fois
sur le projet d'école de gendarmerie
mais aussi sur la création d'un syndicat
qui gère aujourd'hui grâce au grand
dijon et à la grande région
l'aéroport et sa zone d'activité on va y
revenir alors parlons de l'installation
de l'école de gendarmerie à la base elf
et 500 hectares le froid actuellement
vous allez en prendre deux sens pas loin
de temps et 170 principalement les
espaces bâtis du palais piste évidemment
alors pourquoi une nouvelle école de la
gendarmerie vous nous avez dit en
préparant à l'émission qui remet à une
affaire mais ya pas très longtemps au
mans pourquoi on recrée une aujourd'hui
pourquoi ici alors effectivement on a
fermé quelques exemples quelques
infrastructures de formation il ya
quelques années de ça parce que les des
effectifs se réduisent et et puis ben
compte tenu des renforts d'effectifs
liés aux évènements dramatiques qu'on a
qu'on a vécu la gendarmerie a décidé de
rouvrir une nouvelle école de formation
de sous-officiers ça représente combien
de personnes
est-ce qu'on peut comparer devant avec
ce qu'était la base aérienne avant alors
c'est difficile de comparer les deux
structures puisque nous aurons à la fois
des cadres et des élèves dans les élèves
à terme fin 2017
il y aura six compagnies à 120 élèves
qui fera 720 élèves et environ 190
cadres et ils vont arriver quand avant
or précisément les premiers élèves
arrivent le 18 octobre une compagnie de
120 les 120 premiers jeunes franchiront
les grilles de l'école 18 octobre et
puis nous aurons tous les quinze jours
une nouvelle compagnie jusqu'à 4 enfin
fin 2016 et les deux suivantes sur les
six fin 2017
on voit pendant qu'on parle des images
de l'école de tulle alors qu il pas
exactement comparable puisque c'est pas
complètement des sous-officiers je crois
mais ça ressemble dans l'activité est ce
que vous reprenez les bâtiments
qu'est-ce que vous reprenez en fait pour
être concret oui on sait kerry 20
millions d'euros d'investis notamment
pour l'arrivée des étapes majeures ya
pas si longtemps que ça c'est en 2012
alors est ce que c'est un million ils
sont complètement gâché ou est ce que
quand même ça va vous servir à vous
elles seront pas du tout gâcher parce
qu'on récupère des modes de magnifiques
bâtiments donc on va réutiliser dans
leurs fonctions d'état-major puisque mes
cadres ont besoin de bureau etc
donc on reprendra une grande partie des
installations essentiellement le
quartier ferber on se trouve
actuellement il ya les hangars de se
cacher très pratique des matériels des
magasins d'habillement gigantesque et
puis deux grandes salles aussi on peut
former nos jeunes parce qu'ils sont
forts mais aussi dans des salles de
cours avec des ordinateurs mais il ya
aussi une formation physique
intervention qui rendent un stand de tir
donc c'est ça correspond vraiment très
très bien à ce qu'on recherche dans une
école l'armée de l'air avait des stands
et décide périphérique extérieur autour
de dijon vous allez les conserver aussi
oui on conserve de suite donc chez 9,1
un champ de manoeuvre qui est un
chantier mais qui reste champ de
manoeuvre sur le plateau de chenôve où
nos jeunes iront s'exercer aux rudiments
du combat
et puis epagny plus au nord où là on va
créer un champ de tir
on as était à l'origine un champ de tir
peirsol pour les avions voilà pour les
avions donc là ça sera plus modeste ça
pour le fusil jusqu'à 300 m et puis
aussi une zone de manoeuvre donc voilà
on est vrai cela nous fera presque 300
hectares en tout donc vraiment s'est
parfaitement adapté à la formation des
jeunes
est-ce que c'est écoles dijonnaises
longvicienne aura une spécificité par
rapport aux autres écoles de gendarmerie
non elle sera déjà elle sera gâté parce
qu'elles soient dans un magnifique site
et n'aura pas de spécificité en revanche
une spécialisation non non non elle
formera des sous-officiers des deux
jeunes officiers en revanche le schéma
n'est pas figé parce que les
infrastructures sont très importantes et
encore de la marge pour accueillir
peut-être d'autres structures de
formation mais rien n'est décidé mais il
ya un gros potentiel et on compte bien
exploiter josé almeida en 36 on dit que
c'est pas tout à fait la même population
qui va arriver c'est à dire qu'on avait
militaires de l'armée de l'air qui
étaient installés ici avec leur famille
là vous allez avoir beaucoup de
stagiaires qui vont tourner sur des
périodes courtes c'est pas la même chose
en fait
oui mais il y aura quand même des
permanents c'est sûr que le point commun
ce sont des militaires c'est vrai aussi
qu'il y aura moins de famille puisque il
y avait 1200 voire même plus en fait
militaires de l'armée de l'air présent
paravent et c'est vrai que les gendarmes
sont à la fois des cadres on l'a dit
avec leurs familles qui seront
accueillis sur l'on vit sur dijon /
rouge sur la côte d'or
mais il y a aussi les élèves donc c'est
vrai qu'elles ne donneront pas avec leur
famille c'est là peut-être est sans
doute là la différence mais pour autant
toutes ces personnes vont vivre ici sur
notre territoire
colonel reyel comment s'est passée la
transition leur donner les clés
régulièrement que savoir ça se passe
avec les gendarmes
pour l'instant on les accueille sur ce
qui encore la base aérienne jeu
effectivement non on en plaisante parce
que dans quelques quand la base aura
cessé d'exister on se retrouve dans la
situation inverse à avoir des gens de
chez nous qui serons jamais dans la mare
et gendarmes donc oui effectivement on a
tout un travail à faire en commun
effectivement l'appropriation des lieux
ce que comme l'a expliqué le collège
françois et nous de transmettre notre
mémoire sur les lieux de les laisser
faire les travaux dont ils ont besoin de
faire puisque bombe et une base aérienne
s'est passé passait pas une école il
manque un certain d'infrastructure entre
les équipes de journée s'en occupe et
puis petit à petit et bien au fur et à
mesure que notre activité nous diminue
que leurs activités à eux montent en
puissance
eh bien il ya une espèce de transition
naturelle qui se fait je viens meda vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure on a 10 500
hectares globalement va rester 300 ha
non utilisés il ya des pistes ya des
hangars il ya beaucoup de place qu'est
ce que vous faites pour que tout ça ne
devienne pas une friche est ce que vous
faites quelque chose
est ce que vous y arrivez bien sûr on a
fait depuis je voulais dire depuis 2014
avec la création du syndicat donc
l'aéroport
maintenant je préside en fait est non
seulement un aéroport qui était en fait
un produit d'appel qui est basé au sein
d'une zone d'activité économique
cette zone d'activité économique s'est
traduit en fait part des hangars qui
sont maintenant occupés par des
entreprises depuis environ six mois nous
sommes passés de trois entreprises à
l'origine qui est installée sur le site
à 11 donc en quelques mois vous voyez
nous nous développons en fait pour tout
type d'activité en donnant priorité à
l'aéronautique on voit des images de
france auto racing est spécialisé dans
la préparation des voitures de course
qui n'est pas érotique là pour l'espagne
bien sûr ce principalement aéronautique
évidemment et pas seulement et d'autres
besoins réels
d'autres sont en train d'arriver donc
nous en sommes à 11
nous sommes présents dans tous les
salons internationaux en fait aux côtés
de notre exploitants à la snc lavalin
donc au bourget à genève pour prendre
des rendez vous faire visiter le site
c'est ce qui nous a conduit en fait à
obtenir ces onze entreprises au total
avec 70 emplois au total
sur notre site vous espérer aller plus
loin il ya de la marge pour aller plus
loin où la crise économique actuelle
fait que c'est difficile aussi de vous
voyez que celle inverse puisque comme je
voulais dit on passe de trois
entreprises non seulement ça mais nous
sommes arrivés donc parce que nous avons
beaucoup de lien aussi avec les
entreprises de la zone industrielle qui
est à deux pas et donc nous nous sommes
arrivés à un solde positif en matière
d'emploi c'est vrai que nous avons
traversé une grave crise à longvic ya eu
deux fermetures d'entreprises mais nous
sommes parvenus donc il y à peu un solde
positif en matière d'emploi avec la
création en plus d'un nouveau d'une
extension sur le secteur de beauregard
qui concerne landi et rouge
donc vous voyez que tout cela se tient
et que le développement économique est
bien présent et ya une nouvelle
dynamique qui est en train d'être
engagée de qu'on retrouve colonel
françois ça pose pas de problème ça
cette proximité avec un site militaire
et des entreprises entre guillemets
privé pour la sécurité notamment euros
aucun problème le jour n'a remis aux
eaux-vives occurred au coeur de la ville
au coeur des villages donc il
jamais de problème à cohabiter de façon
très proche avec des entreprises 90 il y
aura une clôture qui sera érigée pour
marquer les espaces je crois en revanche
que c'est l'arrivée des gendarmes est
très bienvenue très très bien vu et est
appréciée de toutes les entreprises
pouvoirs des gendarmes dans son
environnement voit sa part assure qu'ils
savaient pas que rassurer cet efficace
on n'a pas parlé vraiment de claude du
de la cible en fait des élèves eux mêmes
quand ils sont choisis sont choisis ici
ça se passe nationalement alors qu'ils
viendront tout là de toute la france
puisque nos jeunes officiers sont ceux
recrutés par concours
comme tous les fonctionnaires ou
assimilés de catégorie b donc concours
national vingt-cinq mille candidats donc
c'est énorme et en fonction de l'heure
de leur classement mais sans corpore par
promotion et ils viendront toute la
france avant on pouvait l'ancien système
effectivement affecté le breton à
l'école de châteaulin le gars de l'est à
l'école de comment aujourd'hui donc on
aura la chance la bruine aura la chance
de voir défiler des jeunes de tous les
horizons et peut-être que mais ils
reviendront certainement qu'ils
reviendront peut-être qu'ils installent
ont-ils aussi quand on prend comme
gendarme une base aérienne on s'aperçoit
qu'on est soumis à quelques obligations
vous avez rencontré des agriculteurs
vous allez aussi dernière vignerons on
peut le dire comme ça
la salle d'avoir une vigne je pense que
l'obligation cessé d'assurer une
transition souple s honda à ce sujet je
voulais remercier la base aérienne
collerait à les élus toutes les parties
prenantes le grand dijon on est reçu
magnifiquement du côté de l'armée de
l'air on peut imaginer que la nostalgie
nostalgie bien avant en revanche est
absolument aucun frein tout est fait
pour que nos sens à l'installation ce
soit facilitée dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
et de l'autre côté il faut qu'on a sur
cette transition en souplesse
il ya des traditions qu'il faut faire
perdurer la vigne donc planté en 85 à
l'arrivée des mirage 2000 le club
guynemer va perdurer
je peux vous dire que c'est une mission
qu'on reprend avec beaucoup de plaisir
ce qui s'appellera toujours clos
guynemer simplement mettra au lieu de
mon mieux sur l'étiquette hommes et
romat ba102 ça sera écoles gembrie de
dijon répit pour le reste pour les
agriculteurs qui exploitent
évidemment j'ai déjà reçu on va on va
continuer à utiliser leurs services à
ces décennies
c'est une c'est un lien qu'on va garder
sont nombreux ils sont cinq agriculteurs
en fait qu interviennent sur l'ensemble
du site des 500 hectares y compris sur
la partie aéronautique aéroportuaire il
nous reste peu de temps allez une grosse
minute démission clonale reali le drap
colonel l'a dit le drapeau regarde oui
on vient on finira par le drapeau un mot
quand même sur eux il ya forcément une
forme de nostalgie c'est pas une mission
comme une autre de fermer une base comme
celle dont on vient de parler ont sévi
dans ses vers appelé en début d'émission
enfin tout le poids du passé qu'il ya
autour de la base aérienne et ça quand
on se retrouve à être le dernier
commandant de base et a donné alors il
ya une nostalgie vous avez raison il ya
dix ans que cette nostalgie elle est
heureusement elle est tempérée par le
fait qu' il ya une fracture à un avenir
derrière une renaissance du site
et ça c'est vraiment un facteur très
positif et le fait que ça reste
militaire c'est important est le fait
que le resto militaire c'est
effectivement important les traditions
voilà restent pris dans son final
alors on l'a dit on a installé le
drapeau c'est le drapeau de la ba102
c'est ça qu'est l'histoire il a alors
oui laure les historiquement le drapeau
qui était sur la base aérienne 102 était
le drapeau on pas le temps de développer
mais de ce qu'on appelait la 2e escadre
de chasse qui maintenant est à luxeuil
sur la base aérienne de luxeuil donc
c'est luxeuil qui a repris le drap pour
que nous avions auparavant mais j'ai
obtenu pour pouvoir faire du de la base
jusqu'à sa fin ce drapeau du groupe de
chasse 3-2 alsace et qu'est ce qu'il va
se passer de 30 juin alors c'est bien le
30 juin vous aurez la lourde tâche et je
peux vous dire que là pour le coup
vraiment
un serrement de coeur à prendre ce
drapeau a le plier à le donner aux
représentants du chef d'état major des
armées de l'air qui sera là et ensuite
ils partie en investissant merci merci
c'est la fin de cette émission spéciale
narcy 12h suivi
merci à nous à l'été mercier l'armée de
l'air nous a accueillis et ensuite avec
des images et des souvenirs de cette
paix à 102 de dijon-longvic au revoir et
merci